字幕: Maki Sugimoto
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさん 想像してみてください
いま あなたは
東北の被災地の
小高い丘の上に立っています
眼下には 雄大な三陸の海が広がっています
海面は 日の光を受けて
キラキラと輝いています
小鳥のさえずりが 聞こえてきます
温かく優しいそよ風が
あなたの頬を撫でます
足元には 一面の菜の花畑が広がっています
いま 菜の花の香りがしませんでしたか？
私はこの光景を実現することが夢です
私のこの活動が東北につながるとは
初めは思ってもいませんでした
きっかけは 私の家の目の前にある
九州大学 六本松キャンパスが
私が小学校６年生の時に
移転したことでした
町からは九大生の姿が消え
一気に寂しくなりました
私は中学１年生になり
なんとかして この大好きな六本松の街を
元気にしたいと思うようになりました
そして思いついたのが 菜の花で —
私の大好きな菜の花で
この街を彩ることでした
初めは たくさん大変なこともありました
種もないし 育て方も知らないし
土地も 行政から借りなければいけません
種蒔きも 独りでするには大変です
そんな中で 国土交通省から土地を借り
無事１年目 綺麗に花を
咲かせることができました
この花壇の周りに
お年寄りの方が座って
談笑している姿を見たとき
横断歩道を待つ人が菜の花を
写真に撮っているのを見たとき
私は とても嬉しかったです
普段は通り過ぎる人たちが
その場で足を止めて
時間と空間を共有している
幸せがつながる そんな瞬間を目にした時
ああ やってよかったなぁと思いました
２年目 私は１年目に断られていた
九大跡地内を貸して頂けることになりました
九大生の方々や
UR（都市再生機構）の職員の方々
地域の方々に種蒔きを
手伝ってもらいながら
2200平方メートルの土地に
菜の花の種を蒔きました
春 見事に咲きました
ちょうどこの頃
九大跡地の工事も一段落し
地域のお祭りが開かれました
［六本松さくらまつり 祭生］
私はこの菜の花を咲かせることで
お祭りを盛り上げることができました
ちょうどこのお祭りに来ていらっしゃった
記者の方にお会いでき
新聞に載せて頂いたり
この活動を書いた作文が表彰されたり
国際ボランティア団体に
表彰されたりしました
そして今 やっているのが
「オイッチニ運動」という活動です
「オイッチニ運動」とは
「０１２」と書きます
何もやらない「０」ではなく
何かやる「１」を選ぼうという活動です
種を私たちの事務局から
希望された方に送り
その種を自宅で育ててもらって
大事に育った —
育ててもらって花が咲いたとき
その人も楽しんでもらえるんですよね
それが枯れた後の種を また収穫して
その人たちの想いのこもった種を
また東北に送ろうという活動です
この想いが繋がる活動を —
活動をしているとき
参加者からこういう手紙を
たくさん頂きました
想いがつながるという感動を体感しました
でも私は 満足していません
なぜだと思いますか？
それは まだ何も東北のために
何も活動できていないからです
私がやっている活動は 偽善ではないのか？
ただの自己満足ではないのか？
そう思ったことが 何度もありました
皆さんは 何か東北のために
活動されたことがありますか？
いま 実際にやっていらっしゃる方も
いるかもしれませんし
震災があった後すぐ 現地に
赴かれた方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
でも私は やりたいという
想いはあるんですが
まだ 実際に東北に行ったこともありませんし
以前 九大跡地で育った あの菜の花の種を
東北に送ったことがあるんですが
それも残念ながら
芽が出なかったそうです
そしていま 私は
協力して頂いている方の土地を借りて
広大な土地に 種を蒔いています
もうすぐ
芽がもうちょっと大きくなって
咲くんじゃないかなって楽しみにしてます
そして将来
私は現地に咲かせたこの菜の花を
小さくても 想いをつなげる産業に
したいという夢があります
私が植えた菜の花から
黄色い色素をとって
例えばハンカチを染めたりして
それを例えば
高速道路のパーキングエリアで
福岡から東北までの高速道路の
パーキングエリアで売ってもらう
そして そこで集まった資金を東北に送る
そういうソーシャルビジネスに
このボランティア活動を
変えていきたいなと いま思っています
みなさんの体の中を
温かい血が巡るように
菜の花の あの黄色で染めた製品が
購入者や支援者の想いを乗せて
地球中を駆け巡れば ー
それが 私の夢です
人がつながって 想いがつながり
幸せがつながる
本当 普通はそういう順番では
ないかと思いますよね
しかし 幸せがつながり
想いがつながり 人がつながる
私はそういう体験をしました
つながることで生まれる幸せもあります
しかし私は 小さな幸せを感じている人が
それをほんの少し伝えられる仕組みを
東北と世界を繋ぐソーシャルビジネスとして
実現したいと思っています
（英語）英語でトライします
［人がつながる］
（英語）私はハンカチを
菜の花で黄色に染めます
そしてその幸せの黄色いハンカチを
福岡から東北までの高速道路の
全ての休憩所で販売します
その黄色いハンカチは 世界中に飛んで
支援者の真心を運びます
まるで温かい血液が
私たちの体中を流れるように
これは単なる金銭的支援ではなく
私たちの心からの贈り物です
私は このソーシャルビジネスの
利益を全て 東北のために使います
あなたの目の前に広がる
一面の菜の花を思い描いてみてください
この活動はきっと幸せを
東北だけでなく
世界中に届けるでしょう
この写真は 幼少期の幸せな私です
私は子どもの頃からずっと
菜の花が大好きです
私は このプロジェクトを東北のための
ソーシャルビジネスに変えたいと考えています
それが 私の新たな夢です
みなさん ありがとうございました
（拍手）